bonsoir voci l'éthique de l'actualité de
ce 22 février langue de porc ou pas
langue de porc les avis ministériel
divergent sur l'explication de la série
de listériose des serait depuis
plusieurs semaines les précautions
maximum sont prises dans les magasins
vers un accord pour un statut
d'autonomie de la corse les habitants de
l'île pourrait se prononcer d'ici la fin
de l'année
à port-la-nouvelle les marins du cargo
le simba échoué depuis la tempête sont
oubliés de presque tous et de leurs
armateurs cinéma les rois du désert où
la version loufoque et tragique de la
guerre du golfe
neuf ans plus tard nous évoquons dans un
instant tous les cas de listeria et la
psychose qui s'est développée ainsi que
la réaction dans les différents magasins
auparavant voyons la situation autour de
monsieur roland dumas il ya comme une
montée de pression politique autour de
monsieur roland dumas celui ci est
actuellement en congé de son poste de
président du conseil constitutionnel
devrait être jugé devant un tribunal
correctionnel d'ici l'été à droite sauf
exception notable de philippe seguin
soucieux de la présomption d'innocence
mais aussi à gauche on évoque la
nécessité d'une démission de monsieur
dumas de sa fonction
reportage chez les boiseries jean
baptiste près d'elle peut-on être le
gardien de la constitution et être
renvoyé devant un tribunal correctionnel
la question taraude juriste et homme
politique certes il y a un an roland
dumas s'était mise en congé du conseil
constitutionnel beaucoup aujourd'hui
considèrent que cela ne suffit plus
toutes tendances confondues
son seul esprit civique simplement
devrait l'amener à se retirer pour
permettre que
la femme de césar ne soit pas soupçonner
c'est à dire que le conseil
constitutionnel qui est appelée à rendre
la justice quotidiennement ne soit pas
l'objet d'un soupçon
le mieux serait pour lui roland dumas et
pour les institutions qu'ils prennent
désormais toutes ses responsabilités il
ya soit sa confiance démissionne ça n'a
pas l'air d'être le cas
fois la possibilité pour les suspendus
la balle est dans leur camp
encore faut-il trouver pour le conseil
constitutionnel les arguments juridiques
certes la loi organique du 7 novembre 58
prévoit que celui ci peut constater la
démission d'office de membres qui
auraient exercé une activité
incompatible avec leurs qualités
certes le décret du 13 novembre 59
prévoit que les membres du conseil ont
pour obligation générale de s'abstenir
de tout ce qui pourrait compromettre
l'indépendance et la dignité de leurs
fonctions deux armes juridiques très
flou qui pousse les juristes vers des
arguments plus techniques et notamment
vers une notion d'équilibré du conseil
l'equilibre du conseil constitutionnel
est rompue simplement du fait que
monsieur dumas ne siège plus et s'il ne
siège pas encore pendant un an deux ans
trois ans il a encore quatre ans de
mandat devant lui j'irai ce n'est pas
tenable
ces scénarios but sur un écueil de
taille est d'actualité
la présomption d'innocence il y aurait
quelques contradictions dumas porsche a
souhaité qu'on renforce les garanties
qu'ils attachent la présomption
d'innocence et d'autre part a demandé qu
alors même que le juge kim n'est pas
jugée il quitte son poste devant ce
dilemme entre le moral et le juridique
les huit autres membres du conseil
constitutionnel n'ont pour l'instant pas
trouvé de solution pour effacer une gêne
perceptible
les 23 cas de listériose décelé dans 19
départements français depuis plusieurs
semaines serait due à la présence de la
bactérie listeria dans de la langue de
porc en gelée je dis bien se réduit car
si la secrétaire d'état à la santé
madame gilou paraître très affirmative
allant jusqu'à annoncer que le
producteur de ses langues de port serait
connu dans les heures qui viennent
le ministre de l'agriculture de son côté
jean glavany est beaucoup plus prudent
affirmant que cette fameuse langue de
porc n'est pas la seule explication
le no thévenet fait le récit d'une
journée d'annoncés des explications
parfois contradictoires sur cette pluie
thériault zh nous sommes des services
vétérinaires nouveau procédé à
l'inspection du rayon remonter la piste
de la listeria c'était l'objectif de
tous les contrôles qui se poursuivait
encore ce matin dans les rayons
charcuterie fromagerie partout en france
aucun produit n'était écartée a priori
par ces inspectrice qui en profitait
aussi pour rappeler quelques consignes
d'hygiène l'idée a lancé quand on change
de produit effectivement de désinfecter
entre chaque produit si ce n'est pas
possible au niveau du rythme etc
c'est au moins plusieurs fois par jour
le désinfecter de façon à limiter les
contaminations croisées
cependant depuis quelques jours les
recoupements effectués par l'institut de
veille sanitaire semblait indiquer que
la filière de la charcuterie était
probablement en cause
confirmation peu après 14h30 cet après
midi par un communiqué du ministère de
la santé
le responsable de l'épidémie c'est la
langue de porc en gelée dominique gillot
secrétaire d'état à la santé le
confirmait quelques minutes plus tard
devant les députés puis dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée nationale
dans les heures qui viennent nous allons
savoir quel est le producteur actuel
pour l'instant je suis pas en capacité
de lui
simplement que c'est le produit qui est
responsable
le 3 2
cas de listériose quelques instants plus
tard le ministre de l'agriculture se
refusait à citer le produit incriminé
jugeant les informations incomplètes
tel produit
la marque le lot sinon ce temps tous les
fabricants ce projet là qui vont être
mises en cause alors que nous avons
des choses dernier acte il ya moins
d'une heure conférence de presse
secrétaire d'état à la santé et institut
de veille sanitaire apporte plus de
précisions les patients n'ont pas tous
consommé de la langue de porc mais à son
contact d'autres aliments ont pu être
contaminées d'autres aliments de façon
accessoire ont pu être par contamination
croisée incriminés dans la survenue de
maladies fait certains des patients
d'épidémie ce soir il semble que l'étau
se resserre autour de trois ou quatre
entreprises
on devrait savoir dès demain quelle
unité de production est en cause on
évoquant la langue de porc en gelée
comme étant à l'origine de l'épidémie
actuelle on ne peut que se rappeler
celle de 1992 qui entraîna 63 morts et
22 avortement d'où l'application très
strictes de précaution dans les rayons
charcuterie des grands magasins
commentaires juliette beau avec mary
pierce amitié philippe naudy première
mesure des précautions dès cet après
midi ces tranches de langue de porc en
gelée sont retirés des étals de certains
supermarchés soigneusement empaquetée
elles vont être stockés à l'arrière du
magasin avant de subir d'éventuelles
analyses cette mesure préventive n'est
pas une première en 1992 même maladie
même responsable à l'époque
l'institut de veille sanitaire mais
plusieurs mois avant d'identifier
l'origine de l'épidémie le bilan est
lourd
279 personnes contaminées 63 morts 22
avortements sont mises en cause les
manipulations au cours de la chaîne de
fabrication
aujourd'hui les contrôles sont plus
sévères les mesures hygiéniques plus
rigoureuse alors pour expliquer ce
nouveau développement de la listériose
nage l'élémentaire véritable bouillon de
culture est pointé du doigt tête je
l'aide à la caractéristique de comporter
un acide aminé particulier en grande
quantité qui est la glycine et la
glycine n'a malheureusement la mauvaise
idée d'être une sorte de casse croûte de
rêve
vous voulez pour la listeria parce que
jeunesse c'est la raison pour laquelle
on ne peut dire que les produits en
gelée sont systématiquement des produits
fragiles et on pourra dire que ce sont
éventuellement des produits à risques si
les conditions de la fabrication et la
conservation sont défectueux ce soir
certains commerçants pourront souffler
un responsable et enfin désigné reste à
identifier précisément la marque et le
lot incriminé
les résultats des analyses devraient
être connus dès demain mais pascal
golomer tout cela donne comme
l'impression d'un précision tout au long
de cette journée ont éclos de la
communication de crise est un art
difficile pour les entreprises comme
pour un gouvernement
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de sécurité
alimentaire on l'a vu ces derniers jours
avec un premier épisode placé sous le
signe du silence silence du gouvernement
le 2 février dernier alors que
l'institut pasteur déclenché l'alertent
à l'épidémie de listeria bien les
autorités publiques décide de ne rien
dire de peur d'affoler l'opinion des
opinions pardon puisqu'elles n'ont à ce
moment là aucune information précise
quant à l'origine de l'épidémie et il
faudra une indiscrétion dans la presse
samedi matin pour que les trois
ministres concernés improvise une
conférence de presse
il s'agit de partir de ce moment-là de
rassurer l'opinion deuxième épisode
placé cette fois sous le signe de la
précipitation cet après midi alors que
les autorités sanitaires n'ont toujours
pas de certitude sur l'origine de
l'épidémie cette fois sur le sur la
marque sur le produit précis et bien
dominique gillot la secrétaire d'état à
la santé décide de parler
et d'évoquer la responsabilité on l'a
dit d'un produit la langue de porc en
jeu laissant plus détails au nom du
droit à l'information des consommateurs
dit elle même si la formation reste
partiel une rapidité qui a en tout cas
eu le don de mettre en colère à la fois
le ministre de l'agriculture et la
secrétaire d'état à la consommation un
cafouillage qui n'est pas de nature en
tout cas à rassurer les consommateurs
merci pascal et demain derrière vous au
ministre de la santé y aurait une
réunion du comité national de sécurité
sanitaire les alertes à la liste
derrière se succèdent depuis plusieurs
années elle alimente inévitablement une
certaine psychose
conséquence les producteurs de
charcuterie sont confrontés à la
suspicion de leur clientèle il y à un
mois la société jacques hardoin situe à
vouvray en indre et loire avait été
sommé de détruire quatre tonnes de
produits après la découverte de traces
de listeria dans de l'eau de rillettes
le patron de la société parle
d'affolement de délire mais comment
maintenant surmonter cet événement c'est
ce que rapporte jean bernard schmidt et
philippe deslandes les gestes respecte
toujours la tradition comme si de rien
n'était la production d'andouillette ou
autres rillettes a repris son cours
comme si de rien n'était seulement car
chez le charcutier ardouin tout le monde
garde en mémoire la crise provoquée il
ya un mois à peine par une alerte à la
listeria 4 tonnes de produits détruit 11
jours d'arrêt de fabrication on n'a été
blessé mais vraiment blessé dans notre
métier dans notre savoir faire dans
notre honnêteté notre intégrité
on a su sam j'ai très mal pris mais bon
je vous dis maintenant c'est du positif
du positif car après ce coup dur toutes
les procédures de nettoyage de suivi des
produits de contrôle ont été
soigneusement revue mais tout cela coûte
très cher on peut pas tout changer du
jour au lendemain dans une entreprise
parce que la qualité c'est une chose
mais c'est un coup énorme en six petites
entreprises
c'est pour ça qu'on est obligé de c'est
un travail de longue haleine
non seulement qu'on travaille ici et
pour ne rien laisser au hasard
l'entreprise ardouin multiplient depuis
un mois les contrôles de qualité
effectués ici dans ce laboratoire
indépendant des vérifications là encore
qui pèseront lourd dans ses comptes
soixante mille francs le double de l'an
dernier c'est le prix à payer pour se
rassurer et surtout rassurer ses clients
absolument tout faire pour que l'image
et la réputation de l'entreprise ne
sombre pas on a eu très peur des
conséquences
et quand tous les médias se mettent à
diffuser il ya un problème de listeria
donc un problème quelque part on se sent
toujours atteint même si c'est si c'est
injustifié et c'est normal le public est
sensible à l'information
un mois après la crise l'entreprise
ardouin espère avoir surmonté ses
problèmes
les mesures drastiques qui ont été
prises lui ont semble-t-il permis de
conserver la confiance de ses clients
des mesures qui lui ont coûté un million
de francs en l'espace d'un mois après
mystérieuse la méningite ce soir la
préfecture de la marne demande aux
étudiants du département de génie
mécanique de l'iut de razz de se faire
connaître pour suivre un traitement
préventif après le cas de méningite qui
a touché un des élèves élèves
actuellement hors de danger on peut
joindre le siège grâce aux numéros
suivants vous voyez 03 26 06 07 08
vous retrouverez ce numéro sur le site
internet de france 2 manifestation de
plusieurs milliers d'agents hospitaliers
de la région parisienne à la mi journée
non loin du ministère de la santé nous
trouvions lrip l'instant les
manifestants réclament des moyens
supplémentaires pour les hôpitaux ça
fait partie des semaines d'action lancée
par les syndicats hospitaliers une
semaine d'action syndicale également
dans la poste avec grève dans plusieurs
départements pour réclamer des créations
d'emplois dans le cadre de la réduction
du temps de travail manifestations elle
lui à paris en fin de matinée
rêver affecté également la poste du
puy-de-dôme aujourd'hui et puis le
ministre claude allègre tient compte des
multiples mouvements de mécontentement
contre la carte scolaire prévue pour la
rentrée 2004 150 postes d'enseignants
supplémentaires ont été accordés pour le
premier degré selon le syndicat fsu
c'est un début de prise en compte
seulement la corse pourrait obtenir un
statut de très large autonomie avec
transfert de plusieurs compétences en
matière d'aménagement du territoire
d'action économique et de d'enseignement
de la langue corse c'est du moins ce que
révèle le journal le monde
après un colloque organisé hier soir à
paris où toutes les composantes du
paysage politique de l'île de beauté
était présente une consultation des
habitants l'île pourrait même être
organisées d'ici le début de l'année
explications avec carole comme c'était
le 13 décembre dernier à matignon en
recevant les élus corses
lionel jospin propose le lancement d'un
processus de réflexion sur l'avenir de
l'île moins de trois mois plus tard le
président de l'assemblée de corse
josé rossi fait part de ses propositions
un statut d'autonomie avancée qui
pourrait être soumis à un référendum
dans l'île
une éventualité déjà évoqué par le
premier ministre cela dépendra des élus
de la corse
cela dépendra peut-être des corses même
si nous décidons ensemble et avec une
autre autorité de l'état de leur
demander leur avis quelle qu'en soit la
forme
un projet qui prévoit d'abord des
transferts de compétences en matière
d'action économique d'aménagement du
territoire ou de langue et de culture
autre évolution les impôts serait
directement perçue par l'assemblée de
corse
ce qui signifierait la fin des
subventions le projet prévoit aussi une
réorganisation administrative avec la
suppression des deux départements
actuels au profit d'une assemblée
territoriale aux compétences étendues
enfin la notion de communauté insulaire
pourrait se substituer à celle de peuple
corse repoussé par le conseil
constitutionnel il ya huit ans bref plus
d'autonomie mais pas l'indépendance
moi je ne souhaite pas faire prospérer
10 des indépendantistes je souhaite au
contraire
or à signer l'accord dans la république
mais d'une autre façon et après un quart
de siècle je crois qu'il faut qu'on se
fasse à une sorte de révision des
politiques on a mises en oeuvre et qui
ont toutes conduit à un échec cuisant
avec ce projet josé rossi entend bien
apparaître comme l'interlocuteur
incontournable aux yeux du gouvernement
et si les nationalistes semble
aujourd'hui d'accord avec l'essentiel de
ses propositions
le projet devra être entérinée par
l'assemblée territoriale de corse le 10
mars prochain jacques chirac a incité ce
matin le gouvernement de lionel jospin à
faire des choix et à prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour prolonger durablement
la croissance ce qui ne paraît pas
actuellement être le cas je cite les
propos du président d'un public
pérennité de la croissance ne va pas de
soi elle ne sera acquise que nous si
nous savons prendre dès maintenant les
dispositions nécessaires pour l'assurer
alors réponse de lionel jospin cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale devant les
députés aux accusations d'immobilisme
relayé par la droite
et puis par le président public ce matin
venez jospin défend son rythme sa
tentative patient dit-il d'allier la
recherche d'efficacité économique et du
progrès social
retour à l'assemblée nationale du député
socialiste henri emmanuelli après deux
années d'absence 2 à des privations de
droits civiques suite à une condamnation
tant qu ancien trésorier du parti
socialiste henri emmanuelli était
longuement applaudi à gauche vers lui et
par quelques rangs de la droite
quant au sénateur dans leur majorité de
droite ils n'entendent pas reconnaître
le génocide du peuple arménien en
turquie en 1915 une reconnaissance
pourtant votée à l'unanimité par
l'assemblée nationale en mai 81 18 mai
la majorité des sénateurs de droite
n'estime pas opportun de discuter de ce
génocide pas question sans doute de
contrarier la turquie candidate à
l'europe aux états unis au texas jeudi
matin une femme de 62 ans devrait être
exécuté par injection une ultime fois
ses avocats demandent que la commission
des grâces du texas fasse réellement son
travail
en examinant le dossier de la condamner
à mort pas seulement les deux crimes
qu'elle a commis mais aussi des
violences dont elle a été victime cette
femme interrogée par la chaîne de
télévision nbc a supplié le gouverneur
bush a
le candidat à la présidentielle de lui
épargner la vie commentaires etienne
leenhardt avec aaron game dans quelques
heures betty lubitsch cette grand-mère
de neuf petits enfants sera 6 à 62 ans
sa vie se termine ici dans la salle
d'exécution une prison du texas
toute l'histoire de cette femme n'est
qu'un long cauchemar enfants battus
femmes maltraitées elle est arrêtée au
début des années 80 pour le meurtre de
son cinquième mari dans le jardin les
enquêteurs retrouveront le cadavre du
mari précédent betty lubitsch et
condamné à mort l'exécution doit avoir
lieu après demain et sur les télévisions
américaines
elle demande au gouverneur de l'état du
texas george bush junior de lui accorder
sa grâce
je demande pitié au gouverneur bush s'il
vous plaît faites preuve de clémence
seulement voilà le texas est l'état
américain qui exécute le plus grand
nombre de condamnés depuis le
rétablissement de la peine de mort aux
etats-unis en 1976
plus de 200 prisonniers ont été exécutés
au texas avec l'assentiment général de
la population
il n'aura échappé à personne qu'en
pleine campagne des élections primaires
george bush junior pour flatter
l'électorat le plus conservateur du
parti républicain n'est pas enclin à
faire preuve de clémence des
responsables politiques américains
utilisent la peine de mort comme un
moyen commode d'offrir une image dure en
matière de lutte contre le crime en
général brice alors que toutes nos
enquêtes on trouverait qu'il n'y avait
aucun lien entre le nombre d'exécutions
est la baisse de la glace
les avocats de betty lobbies sont eu
beau demander et redemander des
circonstances atténuantes pour leurs
clients qu'ils n'ont pour l'instant pas
été entendu si la sentence est confirmée
bêtise hobbit serait la troisième femme
au texas à être exécutée en l'espace
d'un siècle selon les médecins experts
belges ainsi que leurs homologues
espagnols le général pinochet et
physiquement et mentalement ap être
soumis à un procès ils ont donné leur
avis après examen du rapport médical
britannique qu'il aurait été transmis à
noter que le procureur général du
royaume uni a averti les journaux
britanniques qu'il risquait des
poursuites pour avoir publié ce rapport
médical confidentiel au kosovo en
présence de bernard kouchner l'académie
du corps de protection du kosovo a été
créée officiellement elle doit former
des futurs officiers d'aphatie ville à
vocation militaire issu de l'armée de
libération du kosovo nous check 1
à terme cette force comprendre à 5000
membres
au lendemain de la marche de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'albanais sur
mitrovic à la ville était quadrillée
aujourd'hui par les soldats de la kfor
une grande partie de ces manifestants
marcheurs sont rentrés dans la nuit à
pristina mais la journée d'hier restera
très symbolique de la tension entre les
communautés serbe et albanaise reportage
de nos envoyés spéciaux and consignes et
jgc et les échauffourées n'ont pas été
si grave hier sur le pont de mitrovica
plusieurs vagues de grenades
lacrymogènes ont eu raison de la foule
albanaise massés à l'entrée des
quartiers nord de la ville
les balmanais qui se battent pour un
principe le droit de circuler librement
dans ces quartiers majoritairement serbe
les gens veulent rentrer dans leurs
maisons et leur maison elle est de
l'autre côté du pont la manifestation
n'a pas dérapé mais tout de même
elle a largement débordé le cadre prévu
à leur usine certes le service d'ordre
comptait 500 personnes et le cortège
plus de 100000 et cet après midi les
responsables de la mairie de pristina
qui organisait la manifestation
reconnaissait avoir eu quelques
inquiétudes mondiaux femmes achats et
crainte est aussi grande que ma joie de
voir qu'il y avait autant de monde
mobilisé sur cette manifestation s'est
mobilisé dès mars était vrai pour brut
il n'a jamais été question de franchir
le pont répète les organisateurs mais
avec cette manifestation la pression est
montée d'un cran à guînes çeku l'homme
qui a calmé la foule hier
un patron de l'ex uci a transformé
aujourd'hui encore si l'hymne du kosovo
parle désormais d'urgence aux fusées de
mitrovica
il s'agissait là d' envoyer un message
un message très fort à l'onu la kfor et
aux serbes pour leur dire qu'il est
vraiment temps maintenant de régler le
problème de mitrovica au fin fond du
problème et reste aux yeux
les albanais ont peur que ne s'installe
une partition de la ville
ils le savent c'est le souhait des
serbes qui ne se sentent plus en
sécurité que dans leur enclave
car les services thing qu'il y a urgence
pour eux aussi ils sont déjà 200 milles
avoir quitté le kosovo
le problème c'est que la montée en
puissance de ces manifestations jusqu'à
atteindre le niveau de celle d'hier ne
peut que renforcer les serbes dans le
sentiment qu'ils ont est assiégé dans
ces enclaves ratification de la cour
pénale internationale par la quasi
totalité des députés de l'assemblée
nationale cet après midi à paris mais la
france entend faire jouer un article du
statut permettant de décliner la
compétence de la cour pénale
internationale afin d'éviter des
plaintes abusives contre les militaires
français
l'explication gironde boni et christophe
vignal c'est en juillet 98 à rome que
commence le rêve d'un monde plus juste
121 votes sous l'égide des nations unies
pour la création d'une cour pénale
internationale chargée de punir les
auteurs de crimes contre l'humanité et
de crimes de guerre un bémol pourtant à
l'euphorie collective
sept pays dont deux membres permanents
du conseil de sécurité les états unis et
la chine ne veulent pas de cette
juridiction suprême les pays signataires
eux sont entrés dans la phase de
ratification et la france n'est pas en
retard à l'assemblée tous les groupes
parlementaires viennent de voter pour la
cour pénale internationale
mais le gouvernement souhaite que les
militaires français échappent à cette
juridiction
pendant une période de 7 ans les
autorités françaises ont demandé cette
période transitoire pour pouvoir
vérifier que toutes les garanties
introduite dans le statut afin d'éviter
les plaintes abusives sont appliquées
avec efficacité la hantise française
remonte à juillet 95 c'est le massacre
de musulmans de bosnie à srebrenica
les casques bleus sont dirigés par le
général janvier
juge aurait il pu le mettre en cause
pour avoir laissé faire même chose dans
le cas du génocide rwandais
qu'aurait fait un procureur indépendant
dans la sphère du rwanda il aurait mis
en examen et en complicité de génocide
un certain nombre de dirigeants français
parce que c'était l'ère du temps parce
qu'il n'y avait aucune enquête sérieuse
bref on ouvre la porte à toutes les
manipulations possibles et inimaginables
pour les organisations de défense des
droits de l'homme ces craintes ne sont
pas justifiées il faut savoir c'est un
point essentiel que c'est le juge
français qui auraient le primo de
compétence par rapport à la compétence
du juge international donc si le jeu
français dit joie que de tels ou tels
militaire égard et il aura le dernier
mot par rapport au juge international
une garantie que le gouvernement
français ne considèrent pas comme
suffisantes
l'explosion d'une voiture piégée au pays
basque espagnol aujourd'hui à victoria
la vie qu il était stationné sur le
campus universitaire deux personnes ont
été tuées et un responsable régional du
parti socialiste et son garde du corps à
vitoria donc en pays basque espagnol un
large courant international de sympathie
en faveur des réformateurs iraniens
vainqueur au premier tour des élections
législatives dimanche dans le domaine
industriel la compagnie pétrolière total
n'avait pas attendu cette évolution
politique et avait signé malgré
l'embargo américain un contrat
d'exploitation de gaz et pétrole
en 1997 le chantier est immense il a
bénéficié également de capitaux russes
et malaisiens reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux en iran jean-marc 12 et
jean-françois rhône où ils vivent de
leur pêche depuis les générations mais
depuis 18 mois
les quelques dizaines de familles de ce
village arabe de la côte sud de l'iran
on devient étrange voisin pendant neuf
mois
plusieurs milliers de fourmis casqués
ont découpé au millimètre 5 millions de
mètres cubes de pierres arraché au mont
zagros le monstre qui viendra demain se
couchait sur ces 300 hectares de
terrassement et de fondations se
nourrira exclusivement de pétrole au
plus tôt de gaz celui que recèlent les
poches géante du gisement de pars sud à
105 kilomètres au large de l'iran une
usine de traitement du gaz plus
deux plates formes en r + 21 puis égale
13 milliards de francs financé à 40% par
la compagnie total maître d'oeuvre à
part sud
on était jusqu'à maintenant sur les
plates formes en mer
maintenant on commence à terre un projet
trois fois plus gros on pense également
qu'il y aura de beaucoup de possibilité
pour total en iran dans les années à
venir
et en plus on pense pouvoir recruter
assez facilement du personnel très
compétent de 2000 aujourd'hui coréen et
iranien et seulement une quinzaine de
français
la population du chantier grimpera à 10
mille personnes
avant la mise en service l'année
prochaine à lui seul par sud fournira
quotidiennement à l'iran l'équivalent de
la moitié de la consommation française
de gaz un investissement hors de portée
pour une république islamique d'iran
saignée par huit ans de guerre avec
l'irak est toujours sous embargo
américain
alors pour rembourser et rémunéré total
et ses associés russes et malaisiens
l'iran payera en nature sous forme
pendant sept ans de livraison gratuite
d'une partie du pétrole extrait du gaz à
terme naîtra ici une ville de 100000
habitants autour d'industrie de
raffinage et de pétrochimie dont l'iran
installe déjà les infrastructures du
fuel de la compagnie total venus du
pétrolier erika a été de nouveau
constaté sous forme de petites boulettes
dans des criques de l'île d'yeu les
plaques ne sont pas très importante mais
les crises qu'elles sont très difficiles
d'accès et les boulettes noir quevilly
cirma c'est son plus en plus nombreuses
ce sont des militaires de
fontenay-le-comte en vendée qui viennent
actuellement et des ses équipes
municipales côté méditerranée les effets
des tempêtes des trois derniers mois
sont toujours durement ressentie par
ceux que décrivent un marseillais jean
claude izzo appelait les marins perdus
des cargos se sont échoués dans
équipages sont parfois abandonner tout
simplement par les armateurs sur la
plage de port la nouvelle le simba est
ensablé et les marins oublier reportage
karine comazzi et pascal pons sur la
plage déserte depuis 100 jours seuls les
vagues s'approche du simba à bord onze
marins oublier aux sommes appliqués à
fumer ou siroter un thé loin il dit à
leur paisible
siri loin l'armateur dont le calcul est
simple le simba vaut 400 mille francs
sont désensablement quatre fois plus la
solution l'abandon ce n'est pas normal
ce n'est pas un être humain parce qu'il
nous a abandonnés ici sans rien même pas
un billet d'avion de retour
on ne demande rien de plus juste un
billet pour rentrer chez nous ce n'est
pas humain
depuis la nuit de la tempête où il leur
avait porté secours
pascal le scaphandrier du port est venue
presque chaque jour j'ai charrier de
l'eau à peu près 40 tonnes d'eau
j'ai charrier du gasoil à peu près six
ou sept tonnes de gasoil pour faire
fonctionner un groupe électrogène g
charrier de la nourriture
j'ai charrier des chauffages des
bouteilles de gaz enfin tout ce qui est
nécessaire à la vie d'abord de son avis
il y a quinze jours l'état a pris le
relais des bénévoles et ordonné une
saisie le navire sera vendue aux
enchères
un espoir pour ces marins qui n'ont pas
touché de salaire depuis sept mois j'ai
quitté mon pays il ya 22 mois justement
parce qu'il me fallait de l'argent pour
aider ma famille et moi il fallait les
textes de lois internationaux qui sont
gérées par l'onu et l'organisation
maritime internationale sont je dirais
figé par le pouvoir des multinationales
qui ont intérêt à ce que les choses
n'évoluent pas donc je transforme en
négrier de de notre génération actuelle
et qui tire profit de la situation comme
celle ci
alertés par la mission de la mer
l'office des migrations internationales
tente de rapatrier sept marins dans leur
pays les quatre autres devront veiller
sur le bateau jusqu'à sa vente
si tout va bien d'ici un an et demi
plusieurs avalanches sont eu lieu depuis
dimanche soir dans les alpes
autrichiennes suisse et italienne aussi
morts déjà recensés hier il faut ajouter
7 d'un skieur blessé dans le haut adige
nord de l'italie décédé aujourd'hui des
suites de ses blessures tandis qu au
tyrol les recherches sont restées vaines
prat disparition d'un skieur âgé de 15
ans les risques d'avalanche reste
actuellement très important un système
baptisé arva c'est-à-dire appareil de
recherche de victimes d'avalanche permet
de retrouver plus facilement ceux ou
celles qui sont enfouies sous la neige
pascal douce est bon et baisse grenier
on accompagne et un guide de haute
montagne et ses clients pour une
initiation à la rva qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire appareils
recherche victimes d'avalanches c'est à
dire la star des équipements de sécurité
désormais bien connu des amateurs de
hors pistes de randonnée à ski ou en
raquettes
voilà il s'agit en fait d'un émetteur
radio calé sur une fréquence identique
dans le monde entier si un skieur équipé
est emporté par une avalanche
son compagnon fait passer son arva en
mode réception il peut alors rechercher
la victime
plus on va s'approcher de l'appareil de
plus les bips seront rapides le principe
est simple la mise en oeuvre beaucoup
moins voilà c'est parti pour moi je
chronomètre et voir un petit pot le
temps vous mettez le guide à enfouir la
rva sous la neige un quart d'heure après
une avalanche
les chances de survie de la victime sont
de 80 %
elle tombe à 25% après 45 minutes pour
les débutants c'est toujours la même
histoire l'entousiasme d'abord le bon ça
diminue puis le stress au fur et à
mesure que le chrono tourne mais pas
vous une panique qui serait décuplé en
conditions réelles
le pire c'est la recherche finale à 0,81
samedi quand on sait qu'on est tout près
du but sans pouvoir encore l'atteindre
normal quoi
20 minutes un très bon temps pour une
première fois mais qu'il faudrait
multiplier par deux ou trois dans une
véritable avalanche dans des conditions
réelles
le randonneur devenu sauveteurs auraient
en plus utilisé une sonde et une pelle à
neige
les deux autres accessoires
indispensables aux randonneurs on peut
désormais louer des arts va dans de
nombreuses stations mais attention
malentendu ce n'est pas un permis d'un
prudent
c'est loin d'être une ceinture de
sécurité non non il faut surtout pas le
prendre comme ça je pense que même avec
un art va de toute façon la connaissance
de la neige les renseignements vis-à-vis
du du milieu guilou piste heures ou
minutes hors de ce qui est très très
importante
c'est pas parce qu'on à annaba qu'on
peut se permettre d'aller partout
skieurs hors-piste et randonneurs sont
désormais très souvent équipés d'arva
tous n'ont pas encore pris le temps
d'apprendre à s'en servir
du sport avec un fort joli titre de
championne du monde pour corinne niogret
vainqueur du biathlon disputée à oslo
corinne niogret réalisé un sans faute
sur le pas de tir et réalisé aussi une
très belle performance en ski nordique
sur 15km commentaires christelle
bertrand corinne niogret a bien rectifié
le tir
la française remporte la médaille d'or
mondiale du 15 km après deux courses
décevantes en début de compétition
mais cette distance est celle qu'elle
préfère déjà sacrée championne du monde
en 95 corinne niogret double son titre à
oslo en bouclant un parcours sans faute
son début de course est timide mais il
ne va pas l'empêcher de retrouver ses
moyens et son anglais avant la course je
n'avais pas de bonnes jambes je pensais
que ce serait dur mais après quelques
tours je me sentais de mieux en mieux et
aussi aux tirs finalement c'était une
très bonne course et même la meilleure
course de ces dernières années la
biathlète française rapides et précises
devant de 53 secondes la chinoise il
corinne niogret redonne des couleurs à
l'équipe de france orpheline de
médailles depuis 1996 à oslo c'est la
troisième médaille française après le
bronze de raphaël poirée et florence
baverel de la voile avec la coupe de
l'america au large d'auckland en
nouvelle zélande alors pour la deuxième
fois les italiens de prada challenge ont
été battus et très largement ils ont non
seulement pris un mauvais départ et
connu un incident matériel le l'un de
leurs équipiers s'est gravement blessé
vous ne voyez ici
puis alors pour dégager qu'ici une autre
à louis pour dégager le bateau d'un
morceau de plastique que vous voyez un
équipier a dû plonger au bloqué ainsi la
lance du bateau parce qu'il a fallu
ralentir le bateau
bref les italiens sont plutôt mal parti
phase avec l'image de new zealand du
cinéma demain sur les écrans les rois du
désert de david raciale neuf ans après
la guerre du golfe
ce film s'attaque cet épisode militaire
et ironise sur l'opération tempête du
désert desert storm public et critiques
américains ont beaucoup aimé et ce
scénario venue d'un jeune réalisateur
indépendant où l'on retrouve george
clooney présentation pascal deschamps
une séquence d'ouverture qui en dit long
une journaliste et un officier sur
boutonne mai
c'est bien qui vient de posséder l'autre
métaphore des rapports entre l'armée et
la presse pendant la guerre du golfe
et clin d'oeil à mach film sulfureux sur
la guerre du vietnam
vous voulez voir un peu d'action
affirmatif ce film cache bien son jeu
malgré une affiche une bande-annonce
racoleuse les rois du désert et bien un
brûlot anti desert storm qui égratigne
au passage certaines vérités c'est le
genre de film que nous osions faire dans
les années 70 comme match et network et
est à l'époque nous savions rire de
nous-mêmes et notre politique c'est ce
que nous devrions toujours fait il ya un
philosophe français jean baudrillard qui
a dit que quand vous aviez deux cent
cinquante mille morts d'un côté et une
poignée de l'autre on ne pouvait pas
appeler ça une guerre exactement je me
suis senti très mal
c'était répugnons de voir l'amérique se
frapper la poitrine après la guerre nous
avons décimé les irakiens s'il ne se
prononce pas sur la nécessité de la
guerre david o.russell s'interrogent les
midi hier est toujours au pouvoir et
continue d'opprimer son peuple
le personnage du mahjong est joué par
jackie mais s'inspire d'un vrai
militaire qui comme beaucoup d'autres se
demandent aujourd'hui à quoi ont servi
toutes ces morts
la guerre du golfe a été une guerre très
populaire en amérique
85 % des américains ont dit allons-y
allons botter les fesses de saddam les
militaires se sont dits allons faire le
boulot mais à la fin de la guerre ils
n'ont pas compris pourquoi on devait
réarmer saddam et le laisser sans rien
faire massacrer les opposants chiites
watch accès aux films d'action film
politique comédie drame
les rois du désert est tout cela à la
fois il fait en tout cas souffler un
vent d'insolence sur la production
hollywoodienne c'est demain sur les
écrans à la fin de ce journal
ça vous rappeler l'actualité concernant
la listériose leur langue de porc ou pas
langue de porc en gelée les administrés
à divers sur l'explication de la syrie
de listériose 23 décelé depuis plusieurs
semaines des précautions maximum son
prix dans les magasins on pourrait en
savoir plus sur avec le nom de la marque
et des producteurs de la langue de porc
ans je vais s'il s'agit bien de cela
pour tout les listériose décès depuis
plusieurs semaines 9h23 la météo dans
quelques secondes avec nathalie rihouet
et puis après le film de gérard oury
vanille fraise avec pierre arditi sabine
azéma jacques perrin alors heureux
magazine présenté par frédéric lopez 01
vous retrouverez norauto la zapu le
dernier journal de la rédaction
demain 7h50 françoise laborde recevra
dominique gillot secrétaire d'état à la
santé on reparlera de listériose et puis
à 13h vous trouverez ici même carole
gaessler et rachid arhab à demain 20h
bonsoir merci
je
tout ça